[Music]
okay everybody I have the privilege and
honor today to be joined by the one and
only Tony Dalton aka Lalo aka Eduardo
Salamanca aka Jorge de Guzman how are
you doing today Tony I'm good brother
how you doing good man so this crazy
episode just aired episode 8 bag man and
I really really thought a great scene
was just in the beginning with Lalo
talking to Saul here and convincing saw
to pick up his bail money can you
actually give us a little insight into
how Lalo actually views Saul at this
point in the show I think that he can
like some you know I think that's all is
the kind of growing on him
and you know he's his lawyer he he asked
him to go go get this money so I think
he's pretty calm about it you know yeah
yeah I mean do you think though that
Lalo also is honest with Saul like when
he says in episode 7 about that he'll be
a friend of the cartel if he helps him
get out on bail does is Lalo actually
mean what he's saying there is he just
saying what like gets him the next step
no I think that's a thing I think that's
a sort of a thing kind of when you cross
your heart you know you are we in this
together or not and if you not I'll kill
you and if you are then you know you're
gonna make a lot of money it's sort of
like sort of like a rite of passage kind
of yeah right in that too
what you just said about how Lalo is
like are you in this or not what was it
like do you think for the character
voilá when you're playing the part where
he sees Kim in this latest episode for
the first time and he finds out that
Saul actually said to Kim what he was
doing what was your mindset of Lalo
there and why he would react so angry to
that well I mean I think that at first
he doesn't know who she is so that's
kind of what throws him off that's what
makes him so sort of distant at the
beginning is and you know he's sort of
cornered he's in a jail and
he's gonna brought out to speak to this
woman who he has no idea who she is
I'm figures you know probably some kind
of DEA agent or something and then once
she says that she's married to Saul he
said you know he thinks oh this is
perfect for me you know I think that
that's what a lot of things you know
this for me
it's better than it were that it was
before now now I'm actually now he's
actually maybe a little bit more calm
about it because he's not gonna run off
without his wife and Allah knows knows
his wife yeah that's that makes total
sense they're huge
yeah really huge and was that pretty
surreal like you're already a season and
a half being on the show and then this
is the first scene right that you were
with Rhea seehorn
in person on set what was that kind of
like being with like a new big actors
like that
it was amazing was my favorite during
that scene with Reyes
it was great nobody had to talk none of
us bad guys get to work with ray you
know yeah I don't think Giancarlo has
ever worked with ray so being able to
have a scene with ray was so much fun
and ray also I mean Ray's a great great
great gal I mean that she's amazing and
she's a great actress too so doing that
at scene with her was just I mean it was
so much fun we had a great time you just
brought up to jean-carlo I was wondering
when you got the role of Lalo and you
knew you'd be kind of the direct
opposite villain to a super famous
villain and Gus did you feel some sort
of pressure there taking on that role
that you kind of had to live up to Gus
in a way I really know I mean I was
excited about it I didn't feel pressure
I mean you know pressure is when you
have to go get surgery for something
sort of no pressure is staining your
house with coronavirus this is uh this
is just something that you kind of step
up you know you get very few
opportunities in your in your career to
do something like this all right so when
something like this present itself it's
kind of like all right let's play you
know let's do this and also I mean by
the way on another note is Jeff Lewis I
mean just such a you know such a great
actor such a kind and you know
he's a very thoughtful man and he's very
sensitive so he so you know generous on
the set
the first time I did a scene with him
was the last season when I go into the
boys for the metals and talk to him that
I'm eating his chicken and stuff and he
was great you know I was I was I mean I
was nervous because that also that was
directed by Finn so I show up there and
you know Vince Gilligan is directing you
and you get a scene with Gus fring it's
kind of like alright jump into the water
it's uh it's uh really peeps go ahead
take a dive you know it's not like a
little by little so it was I mean but
it's amazing you know I mean what else
could you ask for it's not like that's
that's the kind of things that you want
to do you know yeah and that's just you
say how he's such a nice actor in person
but then your character has to like
despise him what would you say though
for Lalo is like deep down the real
reason he despises Gus so much I don't
think he despises got so much to be
honest with you ok I think that I think
that actor despises him and that's why I
love despises him but he doesn't have a
personal beef with him he's got a family
beef with him you know Lalo it's kind of
like you know kind of like when your
brother or something says don't talk to
that guy I don't like him anymore and
that's it you don't like him anymore
either
you know it's a team effort that you
don't like him ok so this is the guy
that we don't like and let's let's go
after him but it's not as personal as it
is for Hector's you know hmm
philatelist kind and also Lalo is very
you know carefree kind of guy so yeah
this is the guy we hate let's hate him
that's it but it's not like oh my god I
mean it doesn't get to the point where
he's actually doing something to him
personally you know right now that
that's actually really awesome insight
there so speaking to of you're talking
about Don Hector right and when you're
going into this character of Lalo and
you first started playing Lalo
you know this character is really coming
off of that big line in Breaking Bad
about did Lalo didn't send you so where
did you like go in the process with
creating this character from like
scratch did you use some of like
watching Don Hector's character
to go to kind of base what la la would
kind of be like like how does that even
come about well it was a little broader
than that basically what I did was
watched all the Breaking Bad and all of
Saul you know kind of like a marathon
and Kenneth just kind of said you know
what's uh what's missing here you know
what what haven't I seen and kind of
this charm of a bad guy I hadn't seen it
so I kind of decided to to make him that
way a little bit more than than anything
else you know make him a little more
lighthearted you did it everything was
so intense
always so I figured he could say the
same thing the same line the same thing
and then and also meet him but just more
sort of nonchalantly kind of like oh so
carefree or say you know yeah totally
and you kill it portraying that and I
think that that's what I love about the
character of Lalo so much is that he's
psychotic as hell but he's so charming
as an antagonist what I commend you on
is that you never fall into the cartoon
villain territory where I've seen in
like other shows or sometimes the
charming villain can go there and you
don't so are you conscious of them when
the thin line it's a thin line you have
to be really careful with that kind of
stuff because you know it has a lot to
do with I mean to begin with with uh
with the writers and how they write it
that's that's that's kind of like your
Bible you know and then once you're
there on set you decide you know which
way to go especially with with the
director who's on set that day and also
the writers are always all set so you
know they kind of point you in the right
direction yet that one not so much
this year go hear this that's you know
don't don't just you don't want to ever
either put all your cards on the table
or and also you don't want to just seem
like this you know like you just said
like this uh sort of you know smartass
you guys it's just smiling all the time
you know right was there any villains or
characters from other works or just in
real life that kind of inspired your
portrayal of Lalo yeah there's a couple
of things I mean I did a sort of and in
the beginning
kinda had it always in the back of my
mind with this uh Jules Winnfield you
remember that yeah yeah oh yeah Samuel
Jackson and impulsively you know I'm
sorry did I break your concentration I
think you know I kind of just this guy
that just shows up and he just like
talking like doesn't have another care
in the world and then you know when the
[ __ ] hits the fan he gets really mad at
you like everything no that's that is
awesome I feel like fans are gonna love
to hear that also Tony do you think that
you know a lot of actors say when they
play a villain that they have to kind of
see it come from a good place that they
actually think their character is doing
good or is in the right do you see it
that way with your Lalo like are you an
actor who believes and that was like
playing a villain well I mean I don't
look at it that way but well the way
that I do look at it is it I don't think
that as far as I'm concerned as an actor
I never judge the characters that I'm
playing you know they're never good or
bad they're just there's just these
people that you're trying to sort of
understand who they are you know yeah
and and and then if you judge them then
you're gonna play him that way so you
can't ever judge your characters you
gotta kind of be on the side so that you
whatever it is that you do you do it
truthfully you know yeah no that's I
like that and to your philosophy a
little bit of acting there when ask you
another fluffle acting kind of question
but you know you studied acting at least
Strasberg theatre Institute in NYC
it's a notorious home of teaching method
acting are you a method actor yes I mean
I was a hell of a lot more when I was
younger you know I mean I was insane
when I was younger with that kind of
stuff I think that method acting as far
as you know I'm concerned is it's sort
of a way to teach you how to find your
your own voice as an actor and it's
great because it it gets into the
intensity of the whole thing but then
also as a year's group I have been doing
this for a long time you know you kind
of just when you got to turn it off you
turn it off
you know it's not it's not real so just
take it easy you know also it's
exhausting it's you know you you're
doing a television show for what five
six months I mean take it easy and also
what I kind of end up doing is kind of
owning it all over the place so you know
like for example in the case of Lalo I
mean he's just you know just kind of guy
you want to kind of hang out with you
know so you kind of just he just kind of
portrayed that all the time you know did
another one before there was a sort of
very dark peak serious sort of hitman
called senior Avila for HBO and when I
was doing that it was just kind of just
you know the guy you just nobody will
kind of want to hang out with you know
it's just kind of in my own thing so you
you take the message as far as you want
it to but you don't take it I don't I
don't take it like that much you know
you just kind of just kind of skim the
top of it and just kind of always be
that way so that you can see how people
react to you that certain way when
you're in all smiling and doing that and
being very you know charming and things
like that and then just go with it
Wow people listening that act you got to
just listen to all that for some great
advice there and I got to ask you to
being a bilingual actor and you see
scenes where sometimes Lalo is switching
languages in the same scene is it tough
like with lines or just performing that
going back and forth between different
languages I always wondered about that
like can you explain some of that no not
at all it's the easiest thing in the
world really I mean that's yes
that's the way that's the way I kind of
talk I mean I speak to my mother in
English right so but I live in Mexico so
I go back and forth from English to
Spanish all the time do you dream in
Spanish or do you dream in English I
don't know but I do know that I count in
English in my head at the gym when I'm
doing you know whatever kind of you know
those routines or whatever they're
calling I count in English I like okay
just to wrap things up - I saw in your
Instagram you're go to all these cool
concerts you got Dave Matthews van the
now
Roger Waters are you a big rock music
fan and you play any instruments I used
to play the piano I haven't I haven't
gotten on the piano in a while but it
took a couple years piano and yeah I
mean I love concerts in general and I
didn't when I was a kid that much you
know once I went to you know my first
concert I was dirty and there was the
Rolling Stones and after that I said in
missing out here so I try to get some
good music as much as I can right now
it's impossible but whenever it's
possible I go for it
oh yeah and I have one more question for
you Tony if you had to pick do you have
one favorite scene so far that we've
seen that you have been an in better
call Saul maybe the one I did with Ray I
loved working with where she was great
awesome um and you know there's another
one in the next in the next episode but
I can't tell you what it is that's
exciting
don't know when you see it and did you
really jump through that ceiling and
travel wire no I - you maybe be the
Superman moment but no that's you're an
honest man I respect that and do you
have anything you would want to plug
before we go nope just watch your video
so it's gonna get better than ever
oh man I can't wait so you're basically
telling us the next two episodes are
crazy no it's insane it's out of control
I mean nothing less nothing can prepare
you for what's gonna happen I mean you
have no idea thank you cannot wait that
is so exciting to hear yes everyone
please check out Tony Dalton as Lalo and
better call Saul AMC Monday nights at
9:00 p.m. we got only two episodes left
people so we're hitting the finish line
here and Tony thank you so much for
doing this especially in these
circumstances I just hope you your
family everyone is safe and I really
appreciate about their brother thanks
man
have a great day are you - menu - take
care taker